and honestly Jesus still loves me
what is the most traumatic moment of the
season I've had sex in Jesus still loves
me is probably one of the most dramatic
okay
that is a big huge part of me and a lot
of times people get Christianity and
religion messed up because your faith
should be something personal in our
relationship and it's not to judge
others let's say you have had sex with
one or I don't it seems like you felt
judged or shamed yes and it's like
regardless of any thing that I've done
it that people might think oh well that
deserves a scarlet letter that's not how
it works like I can do whatever I send
daily and Jesus still loves me like it's
all washed and do not and if the Lord
doesn't judge me and it's all forgiven
then no other man woman a animal
anything I don't know anything in Hanabi
nobody's gonna judge me I won't stay for
I'm gonna speak my mind about it
to be amazing and yes what a man does
not control anything that I do it's
really my like power play moment okay
like not playing anymore anything you
wish you'd said or did you get it all
out I think I got it all out okay
crystal clear clear you would think but
we'll say you stood up for yourself
honestly my faith has grown so much and
I realized like what relationship with
the Lord is really about I don't have to
carry that to ever have anybody make me
feel that way
it's a little messed up and I'm not
gonna stand for that